you have an English accent on the show
but I'm told it initially you wanted an
American accent I wanted to be American
because I just done this show about a
boy where I was British right and I
wanted to do something different
mm-hmm and she was written as a you know
lovely New Jersey blonde right and so
they came to me I think I was I think I
was at the end of a very long list I
don't think I was at the top of that
list what was it that made you wonder
because you have a lovely accent and I
would think most people hearing it would
think less very charming you want it you
want it very baby funny to be American I
wanted to be I wanted to be something
different yeah that makes total sense I
didn't want to be British right I know
because I am British it's quite boring
for me a light thing you know I like
being an uncouth American yeah
can you okay here's what I'm curious
about can you as and when you're using
an American accent I find it very
convincing when you do it because in
spinning man you're you American accent
yes so we were all doing American act
you're all doing American accents but
you guys are very good at it I think the
English have a very good ear for an
English accent what sounds right and
they know that I mean here if I - no no
anytime my American how's your British I
want to hear your British accent let me
hear it that's very good okay very good
let me hear your British Governor it's
you no no but when I do it
the EBUS are so attuned to different
regions they'll say oh like that's
Manchester that's East Manchester that's
you know that's Birmingham they know all
their different regions whereas the
United States I mean it's a much smaller
country remember yep you guys have more
time on your hands is that you're saying
I mean it does rain more sort of
everywhere right and you do spend more
time in the pub that's what happens a
fine pastime exactly your skills are you
have many skills you can you can speak
very good English acts a British
American accent you're also very good at
a trumpet Wow trumpet sound is that
right yeah and what is this come in
handy to make a trumpet sound how they
you know how they you know how they play
people off at the Oscars when they're
going on too long I think it's quite
useful when people are banging on
particularly if they're in your house
and they won't start talking I think one
should be able to play them off can I
try that right now was pretend I've
dropped in on you and I'm talking and
I'm telling you you know so if I trumpet
let's get lost it means that you know
get lost
yeah that's the rudest I would leave so
quit no I would probably just keep going
I'd be one of those people I'm gone I'm
gone I'm gone
you